pues uno de los puntos uno de las ayudas
financieras que incluye este plan de
estímulo económico de 19 millones de
dólares son los cheques este será la
tercera vez que los estadounidenses
reciben cheque durante este año de
pandemia el cheque será de 1.400 dólares
a las personas que reciban ingresos
menores a 80 mil dólares al año y a los
hogares que reciban conjuntamente
ingresos menores de 160 mil dólares al
año los desempleados tendrán seguirán
teniendo ayudas semanales será la ayuda
de 300 dólares semanales esta ayuda se
acaba este fin de semana y por eso los
demócratas querían asegurarse de que
pasara esta ayuda en el congreso antes
de que los desempleados se quedaran sin
ayuda esta ayuda a los desempleados irá
hasta el 6 de septiembre también ahora
350.000 millones de dólares en ayudas a
gobiernos locales y estatales esta ayuda
también pues se le suma la el dinero que
va destinado a la vacunación y también a
ayudarle a los estadounidenses a pagar
renta
y a las familias que tienen recién
nacidos y cristóbal esta noche del
presidente joe hayden dará un discurso a
la nación que se prevé de su alocución
si el discurso se prevé que dure 20
minutos será a las 8 de la noche hora de
washington y se centrará en cómo
encontrarle una salida a la pandemia se
conmemorará y se recordara alavesa más
de 525 mil muertes de pandemia acá en
eeuu y el presidente hará una hoja de
ruta una baja de ruta de cómo será el
final de la pandemia en eeuu resaltará
además lo que ha hecho en sus primeros
50 días de gobierno sobre todo en el
esfuerzo que ha hecho de vacunación y
pues hay que resaltar que el presidente
joe biden tiene en este momento cerca de
un 60% de aprobación así que pues hará
énfasis en eso en lo que ha hecho de
positivo de cara a la pandemia para
poder que eeuu vuelva a la normalidad